but we begin this morning with the
second biggest bank collapse in U.S
history Federal Regulators shockingly
shuddered Silicon Valley Bank Friday
following the bank's demise the CEO
acknowledged it has been an incredibly
difficult 48 Hours the downward spiral
began Wednesday after Silicon Valley
Bank reported it sold a 21 billion
dollar Bond portfolio at a 1.8 billion
dollar loss the bank then announced it
needed to raise more than 2.2 billion
dollars that sparked a panic-induced
bank run where customers withdrew more
than 40 billion dollars the bank's stock
plummeted more than 60 percent on
Thursday before Friday's final fall the
shutdown also sent shockwaves through
Wall Street each of the three major
indices lost more than one percent
Michael George is here with the very
latest Michael good morning Dana good
morning the fall of Silicon Valley Bank
leaves billions of tech startup dollars
stuck in limbo it's shaken up the global
Global markets and there are fears over
whether this will affect other Banks too
the sudden collapse of Silicon Valley
Bank on Friday is the biggest bank
failure since the 2008 financial crisis
but equity research analyst Alexander
Yocum says this is not the time to push
the panic button most banks I do think
will be okay I think banks are very
specialized
um they definitely need to take this
very seriously also taking this
seriously U.S treasury secretary Janet
Yellen you mentioned Silicon Valley Bank
there are recent developments that
concern a few banks that I'm monitoring
very carefully and when Banks experience
Financial losses it is and should be a
matter of concern banking Regulators
close the bank Friday and the Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation or FDIC
took over seeking to sell the bank's
assets Silicon Valley a favorite Bank of
tech startups has a 175 billion in
deposits and 89 percent of them are
uninsured as of the end of 2022 the FDIC
only ensures deposits up to 250 thousand
dollars
it's unclear what will happen to the
assets of companies like video game
maker Roblox and streaming company Roku
which have hundreds of millions saved
there roku's stock took a 10 dip after
the company revealed its assets are
uninsured I think we got a little bit
complacent over the last you know decade
plus interest rates were super low most
things were working you didn't really
have to think about what would happen if
interest rates went up really quickly
Silicon Valley failed after depositors
race to withdraw money over concerns
about the bank's Health the collapse has
shades of the 2008 financial crisis when
the collapse of Lehman Brothers and bear
Stern sent the economy into a tailspin
now known as the Great Recession but
experts say there are big differences
between then and now majority of banks
will be okay it's really a specialized
Banks and banks that cater to the high
net worth that have a little bit more
concern but at least so far this is not
2008.
now the FDIC says anyone with insured
deposits will be able to access them on
Monday morning the big worry for some of
these Tech startups if they can't access
their money it could lead to workers not
being paid or even laid off Jeff Michael
thank you